in this lesson I'm going to show you the
mechanism for the aldol reaction near
the end of the video will tackle some
retrosynthesis looking at products that
could be formed by the aldol reaction
and thinking backwards about the
starting materials let's begin by
looking at the aldol reaction of acetone
with itself so we have our two molecules
of acetone here I'm coloring them
differently so I can show you in the
product where the carbon atoms end up we
can treat our solution of acetone with
either base or acid and our product will
be in a known we have this purple part
coming from one of our molecules of
acetone these three blue carbons coming
from the other and our new Bond is shown
in red let's look at how this reaction
works beginning with the base catalyzed
mechanism here's our first molecule of
acetone because of the dipole in this
molecule and the resonance we can draw
the hydrogen atoms on this carbon here
are somewhat acidic so our base can come
in and deprotonate this hydrogen atom
and I'm going to show this bond becoming
a lone pair on the carbon atom right
here this step forms in enolate this
enol II has a resonance form and that
really explains why this can even form
in the first place remember if a
molecule has resonance it's stabilized
we can push these electrons in to make a
double bond here and push these
electrons up onto oxygen our
contributing resonance form looks like
this it is fine to show either a
resonance form of this compound because
they both contribute to the overall
structure of the enolate so a bit of the
acetone that's in solution that hasn't
undergone the enol ization reaction can
act as our electrophile and we're going
to get our new bond at this carbon the
arrow pushing looks like this the
electrons push down from oxygen our
double bond can reach out and attack
this electrophilic carbon atom and then
we push the electrons up onto oxygen
this gives our next intermediate now
sodium
is typically a solution in water and
also in this first step when we grab the
proton we made a molecule of water so
I'm going to add that into our equation
right here and now we can use this
molecule of water to protonate the
alkoxide we just made we'll attack the
hydrogen atom of the water pushing the
electrons onto oxygen and we'll form
this beta hydroxy carbonyl compound and
I just want to go back for a second and
just label our enolate here okay so we
have another carbonyl in this compound
we also have this Oh H group that's
inductively pulling electrons so the
hydrogen atoms that are on this carbon
are even a bit more acidic than our
starting material now notice in our
product we don't have this o H we have a
double bond that results from
elimination of this Oh H group and you
might be saying to yourself Oh H minus
is a poor leaving group the reaction
that's going to happen next is an e1 CB
reaction and this is how it works
another molecule of hydroxide can come
in deprotonating here this deprotonation
gives this anion and this anion has
resonance stabilization with the
carbonyl group much like we had up here
we can show this resonance and the fact
that we have all this negative charge
already built up on the molecule will
help to push this group out the
departure of O h minus is not part of
the rate determining step here and
that's what allows this to happen and
have hydroxide leave as a leaving group
with the negative charge built up on the
molecule we can push through all these
bonds to show how the leaving group gets
expelled and this elimination gives the
aldol product and also gives a molecule
of hydroxide if we're looking at this
overall reaction and I'm just gonna add
right here the molecule of water that we
produce in this step we see that in the
first step we consumed hydroxide
producing water
we then deprotonate water producing a
new molecule of hydroxide which we use
in the next step
however in
step here we produce a molecule of
hydroxide overall so this reaction is
catalytic we only need a little bit of
hydroxide to get this to go
since the hydroxide is regenerated in
the end I mentioned earlier that we
could do this reaction under acid
catalyzed conditions as well let's take
a look at that mechanism now the big
difference that we're going to see in
the base catalyzed versus the acid
catalyzed mechanism is the types of
intermediate second form under Basic
Conditions we typically have negative
charges and neutral compounds
interacting but under acid catalyzed
conditions well something negatively
charged like this really can exist with
protons floating around in solution so
we have to be careful of the
intermediates that we form so we can't
just deprotonate this compound in acid
remember we get a negative charge here
so we have a different first step that
activates this carbonyl compound I'm
going to represent our acid as the
hydronium ion and what's going to happen
next is this carbonyl is going to become
protonated the arrow pushing looks like
this and gives an oxonium ion
intermediate and a molecule of water
now with this protonated we have a good
resonance form that puts a carbo cation
right here inductively pulling electron
density from this proton so it is
straightforward under acid catalyzed
conditions for water to do the
deprotonation and we can show arrows
pushing toward oxygen neutralizing that
positive charge so under acidic
conditions our reactive species is going
to be this enol now we need to react our
second carbonyl with the enol but we
can't have it in this form like we had
above because the attack gave a negative
charge instead we'll start with a
molecule of protonated acetone
the arrow pushing will be analogous to
what we have up here except that will
form this positively charged
intermediate once we form this
intermediate water can deprotonate here
forming a new enol the arrow pushing
looks like this and we'll get this in
our media now we don't want to push out
anything with a negative charge like we
did here so we'll need to protonate this
oxygen to make it into a good leaving
group to leave under acidic conditions
if we protonate it can leave as neutral
water we can now do our II 1 CB reaction
forming this charged intermediate that
undergoes a deprotonation to form our
enol and a molecule of acid again the
reaction regenerates our acid and is
therefore catalytic we don't require an
entire equivalent of this for the
reaction to go we need just a little bit
to get the reaction started now I want
to show you how to retro synthetically
analyze the aldol reaction to determine
what starting materials are producing
the aldol product this is especially
important in the event that they're not
the same like we have here with the self
condensation of acetone let's examine
this a known as our example so what I
like to do is just draw a squiggle
through my double bond notice that's the
new bond that forms up here and so then
I can think about this in two parts
let's consider this side first we have
our carbonyl here and the side that
analyzes attacks and and retains the
carbonyl group so this is coming from
the side that ena lized here so for the
carbonyl containing side
we just need to redraw everything up to
the squiggle here's our retro-synthetic
arrow and this side came from acetone
once again now to figure out this side I
like to just think about where we split
the bond and imagine adding an oxygen
atom right back in here where this
double bond is so the starting material
for this side looks like this so see
we're just imagining chopping this bond
and adding back in an oxygen right here
now the conditions up here with
hydroxide or aqueous acid these are
equilibrating conditions each step i've
shown is in equilibrium here so we form
a little bit of our enolate in the first
step that goes on to react this reaction
of two different substrates in an aldol
is called a crossed aldol and across
aldol under equilibrating conditions can
only occur if certain criteria are
met that first criteria is that only one
of the starting materials is enolizable
and the second requirement is that the
substrate that's not enolizable has to
be more reactive we just saw up here how
acetone can react with itself if this is
the more reactive partner in the
reaction
it'll just react with itself and not do
the crossed aldol with the other
substrate however this is a ketone and
this is an aldehyde aldehydes are more
reactive due to both steric and
electronic factors so to perform this
crossed aldol we could mix these two
together with a drop of base or a drop
of acid and this reaction will proceed
to produce this product let's look at
one more example retrosynthetic Li okay
let's do our analysis
draw your squiggly line through the
double bond show a retro-synthetic arrow
the side with the ketone is the side
that analyzes so all we have to do here
is draw out the ketone without being
connected to anything imagine adding a
carbonyl back where we split the bond
and we get these two starting materials
both of these starting materials contain
enolizable protons this substrate has
three right here and this substrate has
some right here and some right here
under equilibrating conditions we'll get
a complex mixture of products so we can
actually carry out this reaction but
it's going to take a little bit of
fancier chemistry if you're interested
in that chemistry you could check out my
video on the crust aldo thanks for
watching